hello and to welcome to this video
Chamberlain rent master Gabrielle off
let's see Queens gambit with black the
tartar cool as always I always feel like
it's slightly risky to play that against
them Russian GM because they they
probably learned this stuff when they
are six years old and I just well when I
play it but I don't really I don't
really feel like um yeah knowing it well
okay see what is he doing here a 5 has
set a problem not sure him I don't think
a six is a problem I mean him if he
plays a six now I think that just gives
me b6 for the night yes of course he
wants to put his to put it on c5 here
but I'm not sure how bad it is if I get
in Bishop c8 here no he allows me to
trade that
hmm
ok
hmm I wonder do I get it to to see for
here
95 there's nothing particularly
threatening 95 though this is this is
something else
nine f5 this also i takes d5 sometimes
violin I Tandy six hmm
who didn't look at this move it over
I see point is this is really not
looking good
okay if I get to the six I'm okay here
I'm not sure let this help some ways
that some wacky tactic my day six or
something wacky I don't know there is no
we're tactic then I'm okay here the
night comes to c4
I thought Bishop g5 is a move now
okay let's jump him
nice click on the e-file this is still
better for him
you
still got trouble here that is to piss
quicker on the e-file and a success
remaining week
you
okies wants to play technically here
understandable time morning so if I can
only go here Wow
don't think is that so bad
doesn't feel so bad thirtysomething
seconds
check check check check oh my goodness
check yeah first you outplayed me
totally oh now blending the rook here
Wow ok I would have lost some time
resins and then he blunders it all back
here in turn that end game maybe still
lost but you have who I was really bad
chan does this kind of phone structure
is always always tricky business if I
get to the six and to see for everything
is very ok but I never got them I never
got them but should you for it's very
interesting
not sure that this idea would have
occurred to me trading off that rotten
bishop but the resulting position is
very a very good fam I don't I don't get
get to the sex I want it done I d7 f56
but I couldn't couldn't make it work
yeah night at five this night 95 and
this is also great home I felt I
shouldn't be in such bad shape but
probably that was bad yeah the resulting
position isn't good I I should do this
the computer is pretty optimistic here
with this thing now that sounds very
care yeah I see that this is okay now I
have this idea but this is difficult to
play threatening made only one also so
something oops something like that and
here I'm fine but now I didn't I didn't
see that after that I'm just in bad
shape and I think he played that really
okay always keeping keeping big pressure
okay here yeah okay that this wasn't the
best I was ok king of a player winning
the rook if it wins the rook now can t
everything is good again yeah okay there
was the odd blunder but all is all I
think the white witness of Jesus kind of
okay m
whether the game went most of it okay
thanks for watching